[Music]
yesterday HBO pulled gone-with-the-wind
from its lineup of movies it's now
forbidden in Dallas the city government
removed a statue of the Texas Ranger
meanwhile NPR National Public Radio
which you pay for recently promoted a
piece readers to quote decolonize their
bookshelves and discard colonialist
ideas that pervaded the American psyche
for so long so here we have censoring
movies ripping down statues encouraging
book burning what does that have to do
with police brutality well nothing these
are attacks on our shared history and
our culture this is a topic worth
discussing and there's no one worth
discussing it more with than the great
mark Stein here joins us site for the
first time in three months mark Stein
would you mind holding up today's
newspaper to establish that it is in
fact you and not a hologram I'd love to
hold up today's newspaper but it went
out of business six weeks into the
pandemic when they quarantined they
quarantined all the newspaper boys
because the best way to get covered is
by throwing the infected newspaper on to
your neighbor's doorstep so that's all
over Tucker you got to keep up we've
missed you bark so what you're watching
all of this from seclusion none of this
seems to have anything to do with police
brutality what's going on well two to go
to the theme you've been talking about
tonight and last night where are the
people who will defend this you can't
have a culture war if one side refuses
to turn up on the politics on the
looting on the rioting the Republican
Party and conservatives have been
largely silent and similarly on the
culture war they've the other side has
been largely silent people it's not it's
not the young snowflake generation who
are easily triggered it's the
middle-aged guys running HBO and these
other corporations why are they not
defending this they've made millions off
of Gone with the Wind
if people don't like it fine if that's
not your take on the antebellum self
make your own movie write your own novel
do your own play about the antebellum
self
but don't demand things be abolished
simply because they weren't made with
the peculiar narcissistic sensibilities
of 2020 in mind so our entire culture
exists digitally now it's very difficult
to get rid of all copies of Catcher in
the Rye is very easy to eliminate an
e-book you can do it in a keystroke
should we be worried about erasing our
culture or past our civilization
absolutely you you say digitally they're
easy to find I'm not so sure we maybe at
the beginning of one of those dystopian
tales where in a few years time somebody
stumbles across the last rustling video
cassette recorder in the woods and there
happens to be a tape of Gone with the
Wind and they stick it in and they
marvel at it because they've never seen
this before they this generation is a
hyper present-tense generation and
unfortunately it's determined to destroy
everything it doesn't understand which
is quite a lot so I just have to ask you
about your whereabouts now you sent word
to our staff that you were in a cave in
Kandahar but I noticed that you're tan
so I I don't think you really were where
have you been you can get a great tan in
a cave in Kandahar I'm I was a very low
ranking jihadist I didn't qualify for
the executive latrine but actually
property is incredibly reasonable in
Helmand province if you're thinking of
somewhere to flee to you know let's
let's be honest when the powder keg goes
up the cave at Kandahar will be looking
pretty good I'm if I'd come back
last month Tucker I would have done
lockdown stick if I'd come back last
week I would have done looting stick but
right now I'm looking for the neither of
the above box because the choice between
either being locked down in every aspect
of your life or being allowed the run of
the streets because white supremacy is
an
even greater public health crisis than
Co vid III I'm looking for the neither
of the above box in those two choices
I'm not surprised to learn that unlike
the rest of us you figured out a better
way to live some day I hope to find out
what exactly it was mark Stein again we
are very glad to have you back thank you